[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por natalia
cabrera esto es a qui américa el
programa donde revisaremos en
profundidad las historias y las noticias
de nuestro continente hoy hablaremos de
la migración en eeuu en su primera rueda
de prensa el presidente joe biden
criticó las políticas migratorias de
méxico y de su antecesor donald trump en
brasil la tercera ola del virus alcanzó
tal punto que el presidente ya ir
bolsonaro cambió por primera vez su
discurso y anunció la creación de un
comité de emergencia mientras los países
vecinos empiezan a tomar medidas para
protegerse de las variantes brasileñas
del virus por otro lado argentina
reafirmó su respaldo a venezuela y ya
formalizó su retiro del grupo de lima la
coalición de una decena de países
latinoamericanos que desconoce a nicolás
maduro como presidente de venezuela hoy
explicaremos por qué los argentinos se
retiraron
comencemos entonces con eeuu la tensión
por el aumento de los migrantes hizo que
el presidente joe biden creará un grupo
diplomático de élite encargado de frenar
la migración y ahora la vicepresidenta
kamala harris es quien estará a la
cabeza va a ir en profundizó su posición
sobre el tema durante su primera rueda
de prensa como presidente sólo que esa
vez aumentó el tono de la discusión y
culpó directamente a donald trump de lo
que está ocurriendo en la frontera sur
que hizo trump y tendió y eliminó ese
financiamientos no lo uso y además de
eso lo que hizo fue desmantelar todo lo
que existe para hacerle frente a lo que
ha sido un problema durante mucho tiempo
dawn y de hecho cerró la cantidad de
camas disponibles dio financió el
departamento de salud para que sacar a
los niños de las instalaciones de la
patrulla fronteriza donde no deberían
estar se supone que no deben estar allí
más de unos pocos días pero él
desmanteló todo eso
también habló de lo que está haciendo
méxico con los migrantes aunque el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
ya había advertido que no permitiría que
lo supervisarán y los trataran como
colonia el mandatario estadounidense
criticó las políticas migratorias
mexicanas
que hay cerca de las familias porque
algunos no regresan porque méxico se
niega a recuperar los están diciendo que
no los aceptarán
estamos en negociaciones con el
presidente de méxico creo que veremos
ese cambio todos deberían volver todos a
joey pib las únicas personas a las que
no vamos a dejar que se sientan solas al
otro lado del río grandes sin ayuda son
los niños
otro de los grandes debates en eeuu es
la regulación de armamento después de
dos tiroteos en una sola semana el
presidente joe biden pidió que se
prohibieran las armas de asalto pero
esto no es fácil los demócratas y los
republicanos nunca han logrado un
consenso en el tema y las asociaciones
de armamento hacen un gigantesco lobby
para evitar que se cambien las leyes
veamos los detalles en el siguiente
informe
10 muertos en un supermercado en
colorado 8 mujeres la mayoría de
ascendencia asiática perdieron la vida
entre salones de masajes en georgia
ambos tiroteos ocurrieron con tan solo 5
días de diferencia ante la conmoción el
presidente joe biden pidió un cambio en
las normas del país
no necesito esperar un minuto más y
mucho menos una hora para tomar medidas
de sentido común que salvarán vidas en
el futuro y para instar a mis colegas en
la cámara y en el senado a actuar una
vez más podemos prohibir las armas de
asalto y los cargadores de alta
capacidad en este país sin descanso pero
el camino a una prohibición es complejo
el derecho a tener armas está protegido
por la segunda enmienda y más que hacer
un derecho legal es una batalla política
que se ha perdido por años en el
congreso se han caído varios proyectos
de ley para controlar las armas aunque
ahora los legisladores demócratas lo
intentan de nuevo la cámara de
representantes ya aprobó dos propuestas
que obligarían a verificar los
antecedentes del comprador antes de
venderle armas
la gran mayoría de los republicanos votó
negativamente y esa puja podría hundir
los proyectos en el senado reforzando la
división partidista está la asociación
nacional del rifle este organismo que
apoya principalmente a los republicanos
gasta cerca de 250 millones de dólares
cada año en defensa de la segunda
enmienda solo el lobby invirtió más de 5
millones de dólares en los últimos dos
años todo esto hace que la regulación de
armas en eeuu sea difícil de lograr
y ahora vamos a brasil porque el cobre
19 presiona cada vez más al gobierno de
jair bolsonaro el país ya superó los
300.000 fallecidos a causa del brote y
tanto la comunidad internacional como
los ciudadanos le piden cambios al
presidente para contener la propagación
del virus la ope se dijo que era crucial
que el país tomara medidas frente al
coronavirus y países vecinos empiezan a
tomar medidas para evitar la llegada de
la variante brasileña a sus territorios
entretanto en las calles brasileñas los
ciudadanos rechazan la gestión de
evolucionaron con cacerolazos aunque el
mandatario se ha caracterizado por su
negacionismo del brote la nueva
situación lo impulsó a crear un comité
de emergencia para intentar revertir los
devastadores efectos de la pandemia
luís muñoz nos explica este cambio de
discurso
cuando empezó la pandemia mientras los
países se confiaban el líder brasileño
seguía saludando a los suyos sin
mascarilla y sin distanciamiento social
para bolsonaro el virus no era para
tanto después de la puñalada que recibí
no va a ser una gripe sin ya lo que me
va a derribar de acuerdo bolsonaro se
contagió de kobe 19 y aún así continuaba
negando su gravedad y promoviendo
medicamentos de dudosa efectividad como
la hidroxi cloroquina las imágenes de
hospitales y cementerios saturados daban
la vuelta al mundo
castigando especialmente el amazonas
donde han muerto más de mil indígenas
una región golpeada por la aparición de
variantes más contagiosas
efe corona virus es un problema muy
grave tanto para ustedes como para los
pueblos indígenas pero al presidente
brasileño no le importamos el virus no
derribó la salud de bolsonaro pero sí su
credibilidad internacional y sus niveles
de popularidad la ciudadanía comenzó a
protestar más frecuentemente en su
contra la falta de medidas y de insumos
le han llevado a enfrentarse en diversas
ocasiones con gobernadores y jueces
buscar acuarios
lo que quieren estos tipos en nuestra
sangre nuestra libertad esa es la verdad
lo que hicieron con el virus la
porquería del gobernador de sao paulo el
de río de janeiro exactamente eso
el ministerio de salud vio desfilar ya
al cuarto ministro en un año que es en
este punto cuando parece que al fin el
presidente bolsonaro va a enfrentar
frontalmente la pandemia con la creación
de un comité para coordinar medidas
semanales con los gobernadores la vida
en primer lugar resolvimos entre otras
cosas que se creara una coordinación
conjunta con gobernadores así como el
presidente del senado federal
ha dado un panorama que alertan que
todavía puede empeorar para que queda la
esperanza de un lento proceso de
vacunación para revertir la situación
sigamos con estados unidos para revisar
otras noticias de las américas esta
semana ya comenzó el juicio contra el
policía directo a bing acusado de haber
asfixiado al afroamericano george wood
pero para iniciar las deliberaciones
primero la justicia estadounidense
atravesó por un largo proceso para
elegir al jurado la mayoría de los
cientos de candidatos fueron rechazados
porque tenían alguna opinión sobre floyd
y sólo después de dos semanas se
eligieron 15 personas incluyendo 3
suplentes
el jurado lo conformarán nueve personas
blancas cuatro afroamericanas y dos
multirraciales la diversidad será la
clave para determinar qué tan legítimo
es el juicio del caso de racismo más
significativo de los últimos años
en colombia una de las noticias es el
más reciente informe del comité
internacional de la cruz roja el
organismo reiteró que en el país existen
cinco conflictos internos entre
múltiples grupos armados y el estado
además comprobó que durante la pandemia
los grupos ilegales reforzaron su
control sobre los territorios mientras
que la situación humanitaria se agravó
con más víctimas de minas antipersonal y
más ataques al personal sanitario
en honduras el tema principal sigue
siendo el proceso contra el presidente
juan orlando hernández quien fue
señalado de haber cooperado
supuestamente con el envío de drogas a
eeuu la justicia norteamericana ya
condenó al narcotraficante que
presuntamente era el socio del
mandatario pero hernández rechaza los
señalamientos y dijo que tenía audios de
la dea que prueban su inocencia
sigamos con argentina la noticia de esta
semana en el país austral fue su retiro
del grupo de lima el gobierno argentino
considera que la presión que una decena
de países latinoamericanos ejerce sobre
venezuela no ha llevado a nada y reitero
que son los venezolanos los que deben
solucionar la crisis este no es el
primer país que se aleja del grupo de
lima veamos la historia de esta
coalición en el siguiente reporte
argentina ya no hace parte del grupo de
lima aunque el país sudamericano
oficializó su postura el 24 de marzo
realmente se venía alejando del
organismo desde tiempo atrás la historia
del grupo de lima comenzó en agosto de
2017 cuando los cancilleres de 12 países
latinoamericanos hicieron un bloque para
rechazar el gobierno de nicolás maduro
en venezuela y pedir el regreso de la
democracia a la argentina de mauricio
macri hizo parte de esos países la
comunidad internacional ya se dio cuenta
maduro es un dictador que busca
perpetuarse en el poder con elecciones
ficticias
encarcelando opositores y llevando a los
venezolanos a una situación desesperante
y agónica el grupo de lima tuvo momentos
de mayor visibilidad en 2019 cuando
impulsó el llamado cerco diplomático
sobre venezuela una presión conjunta de
varios países latinoamericanos para
forzar la salida de nicolás maduró algo
que el gobierno venezolano rechazaba la
república bolivariana venezuela expresa
su mayor perplejidad ante la
extravagante declaración de un grupo de
países del continente americano que tras
recibir instrucciones del gobierno de
eeuu a través de una videoconferencia
han acordado alentar un golpe de estado
en venezuela con el tiempo el colectivo
perdió protagonismo y maduro siguió en
el poder con nuevo presidente es méxico
y bolivia se alejaron del colectivo y lo
mismo pasó en argentina
en octubre de 2020 el grupo de lima
ratificó su respaldo a juan guaidó como
presidente interino de venezuela pero el
gobierno de alberto fernández no afirmó
el comunicado ahora formaliza la lejanía
separándose definitivamente del grupo la
república argentina formalizó su retiro
del denominado grupo de lima al
considerar que las acciones que ha
venido impulsando el grupo en el plano
internacional buscando aislar al
gobierno de venezuela ya sus
representantes no han conducido a nada
por otro lado la participación de un
sector de la oposición venezolana como
un integrante más del grupo de lima ha
llevado a que se adoptarán posiciones
que nuestro gobierno no ha podido ni
puede acompañar a transmitir a su no
celebran la decisión otros consideran
que es un respaldo negativo a venezuela
lo macro y terminamos nuestro programa
con la imagen de la semana las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 que está produciendo
cuba el país asegura que para junio sus
dos candidatas soberana 2 y abdalá
estarán listas para comenzar el plan de
vacunación en la isla éstas podrían ser
las primeras inoculaciones desarrolladas
localmente con autonomía en américa
latina' algo en lo que ese país tiene
experiencia pues comenzó a desarrollar
sus propias vacunas desde los 80 ante el
bloqueo que le impuso eeuu dos décadas
atrás
esto es todo por hoy gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí y
américa recuerden que pueden seguirme en
las redes sociales que ven en sus
pantallas soy maría clara calle por
natalia cabrera sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]